- The last time you were here,
you'd taken up gardening.
How's that going?
Cause my yard looks fantastic.
- Does it?
- Yes
- How's the plant that I got you?
Remember last time.
- Its good I'm telling you.
Yes. I've named her Beth.
- Oh my god.
- Here's the thing.
And I have a whole area, like
my dining room, like out.
And I actually feel proud too,
I actually use my dining room.
- I'm so proud also.
- Nobody uses a dining room
really like where I'm from.
- No!
I have clothes all over it.
- I'm just. Nobody uses it.
We've been using it and right outside it
there's like these doors that open up
and there's this whole
little area of like,
yeah, just potted plants.
It's beautiful.
- The plants are like my children outside
when I like lose one. I'm like no.
- My daughter hates plants
because I love them so
much 'cause she's like,
are you going to go with the plants again?
You're gonna go water the plants.
So I seriously think
I'm going to have a kid
that hates plants.
'Cause she's like,
oh, is it your time with the plants again?
I'm like, I've gotta water them.
- This is Mommy time.
- Yeah. This is therapy,
go play with Legos.
- She's like, I'm an indoor kid.
- Jump on the trampoline.
(audience applauding)
But you also get your time to
try some new sports, right?
I hear.
- I tried some new sports Kelly.
- Okay. Well what sports?
- I tried golf for a couple of weeks.
- Hey.
- It's too hot. I can't play golf.
- If you need someone to drive
a cart and drink with you.
- Oh, I could do that.
- Okay.
- If it's shaded and air
conditioned in the cart.
(Kelly and Beth Laughing)
But now, I've discovered
something that is amazing
and a real thing called slow jogging.
Have you heard of this?
- I mean, I think I do it.
- Okay me too.
- But no, but wait. But
It's a. Me too, me too.
Me too.
But its a real thing.
It's a, it's a Japanese,
there's a whole book about it.
You can read about slow jogging
and they say to run it in nico pace.
Nico pace, which means
that you smile as you run.
So it's always supposed to
put a smile on your face
and it's slower than walking.
Like you're literally like.
And I swear and it's
so good for your legs,
makes you smile the whole
time. It's not stressful.
- Oh.
- So I'll be like running
through my neighborhood,
literally like.
(Kelly and the audience laughing)
Honey, I swear to god.
But it makes me so happy.
Google it.
- Y'all are laughing and
you're gonna google it.
I asked my husband. I genuinely do this.
I did it this morning.
- I just genuinely love
that your neighbors
are like, what's wrong with her?
(kelly laughing)
Just getting my workout in.
I love it.